welcome to the bonus show everybody
we're going to be talking about this
insane winter storm which which may
cause
more southern infrastructure disasters
we'll talk about it we're also going to
talk about the national debt but first
i've been told that because it's my
birthday there is what should i say
there is a video is that what i'm
supposed to say exactly yeah well first
of all happy birthday to you david thank
you from me from producer noah from
producer john uh we expect that your
38th year of life or 39th depending on
how you count it yeah to be
remarkable and eventful in more ways
than one yeah so happy birthday to you
hope you have a great day and a great
coming year but uh yes there is a video
from the team that you have to open up
now and play and watch live for the
first time okay so i've not seen this
yet so i'm
i hope that the size is correct i'm
gonna open the url here and let's see
what happens
oh wait hold on it's me i'm in the video
this is bizarre wait is it
oh is this a cat did you guys get me to
do a cameo for myself
you're gonna have to play all right hold
on i'm gonna play it now let me let me
make sure we have the right framing here
uh
oh okay this is pr i think i got it
let's see
hey dave david pakman here just wanted
to say hi and thank you for your support
of the david pakman show really couldn't
do it without
uh people like you i mean i imagine what
would it be like without people like you
and it's me in a room by myself with
lights talking to a microphone and
nobody's listening it's creepy it's sad
and it would be really horrible so i
can't tell you how much i appreciate you
and your support
we're hoping for i mean listen we're all
hoping for a better 2022
2021 hopefully massive dumps of
elections being won
in november
and all of these other things better
from a public health standpoint better
from a political standpoint all of it so
i hope you're doing well can't tell you
again how much i appreciate your support
and hope it is a fantastic rest of the
year
right
wow okay so now what i need to do now is
i need to figure out see i vaguely
remember getting a cameo for a david
yep and i'm trying let me see if i can
remind myself what the thing was
i don't think there was anything weird
about it that's the thing we were
thinking about setting it up so that it
would be for david and a special happy
birthday wish but we thought that that
would be a little bit too suspicious so
instead of david we went with dave and
instead of a birthday message we just
sent uh you know we we decided to set it
up as just sort of a general positive
feelings happy message and it seems to
have worked because you weren't you were
uh fooled by it i had no idea now what i
want to do so is this cameo for dave
from five days ago exactly okay let me
look at it
so
oh you know i found this one to be weird
and i'll tell you why
it said my friend dave big fan has been
sad lately cheer him up with a message
from you and the team but don't mention
him being down and i have to tell you i
i had no idea that it had to do with you
and my birthday like i'm not saying that
but i did think i was like weird if you
want me to cheer someone up without
acknowledging that they've been down
it's just sort of a little bit weird and
i remember looking at it a couple of
times but i obviously didn't connect it
to you
well yeah the theory was that this would
make it so that you would sort of
complement this dave right in a way that
you know you wouldn't normally do to
yourself like you wouldn't say positive
things about yourself and call yourself
intelligent and yeah you know all of
these different things uh but we thought
that because we said that uh okay this
person has been feeling down about
himself that maybe you would gas
yourself up in this way right so it kind
of worked it did work in that way it is
funny because
it did not go unnoticed that there was
something weird about the request but i
was just kind of like maybe the person
isn't being public about the fact that
they're in a depression or like i just
had no idea what the explanation was but
i was like i'll just do it i'll do
whatever they're asking me to do well
yeah happy mess happy birthday message
to david that definitely would have
given it away right and uh of course
that can't be the only thing that we
give to you on your birthday so we also
have a six pack of graters ice cream
that's going to show up to your door
sometime today and uh these are the
flavors that we picked out black cherry
chocolate chip beautiful dark chocolate
brownie nice vanilla
or oregon oregon strawberry
vienna coffee and caramel macchiato
beautiful beautiful the macchiato and
we'll go we'll put that one in the trash
but the others are really good no that's
uh those are all great flavors thank you
so much that's really great in fact i
think i i think something was just
dropped off
um and it's so cold out that if it's ice
cream it's gonna be absolutely fine
that's fantastic love the graters
yup so happy birthday we hope you have
an excellent year